please welcome back out Mike Mitchell
Walt Dohrn scheana Shay Anna Kendrick
and Justin Timberlake
you wanna I think for each question you
answer you just moved down to a
different microphone so mix it up
congratulations on the movie are you
excited showing a comic-con in front of
as many people are you kidding yeah it's
like we said we really have been waiting
for this moment for three years so tell
us a little bit because the the film is
a little bit of a 70s vibe so you want
to talk about that kind of aesthetically
where it came from Gina and why you guys
decided to make it look this way yeah we
all played with our trolls in the 70s
and our shag carpets listening to ABBA
going rollerskating with the trolls in
our pocket so we wanted that kind of
feeling of freedom and love and
happiness to influence the trolls
society and then for the bergens we went
the other direction of the 70s and we're
influenced by the brutalist sculpture
and polyester side of the 70s they are
monsters after all but the whole feeling
has like a crocheted blanket
yeah our production designer Kendall
Cronkite she was like she said the
seventies is almost like a fairy tale
time that no one remembers like a phone
with the cord on it
I don't remember I'm 23 yeah for differ
reason even 1900s what but this with the
soundtrack though you guys really did
bring in you know Hertz you covered all
the decades Hertz sound of silence I
heard guerrillas in there was that would
you produce the soundtrack Justin well
yeah well so I guess I guess so I guess
I did um your Justin Timberlake we're a
comic okay got it
okay um yeah I'd never thought you know
I'd ever have an opportunity to you know
it's like I we re working you know Simon
& Garfunkel and Earth Wind & Fire and
you know gorillas and it's a it's been a
lot of fun you know getting to play a
character obviously and you know I was
sold on it when they said Anna was in so
I was but
and then I got to know her a little bit
and I realized I would I had already
signed the contract no no but so I was
excited just to be in the movie and then
to have the opportunity to help craft
the story with the music um it was it
was just a dream come true it's a dream
factory will suck it's just a dream
works oh man I know I know
tree shut up
can't stop the feeling by the way I just
looked at this morning's like a hundred
and twenty six million views on YouTube
right now it's insane that's awesome
congratulations thank you thank you when
you're when you're when you're building
songs for a movie like this or how
closely with the directors are you
working you already have something in
mind or do they go here's sort of the
landscape and the map of the universe
what do you think how does that work uh
do you want to well yeah I mean we have
a whole bunch of different sounding
songs in this and Justin really helped
us make it a cohesive feel like a
cohesive all the songs fit together and
then he was also very helpful in it all
the songs tied into story wall tonight
like to like make sure that the movie I
don't know if you notice but the movie
doesn't just stop and there's a song it
the song is telling a story and adding
to the story and Justin was really
instrumental what's your word Adam well
and again creating that cohesiveness we
call Justin our sonic wizard sonic
wizard sonic wizard yeah was very
helpful you have to say three times like
that every time you do a echo yeah I'm
currently getting a business card made
that title song wizard and it's so what
can you tell I mean obviously we saw a
poppy a bit she seems fun she seems
incurably optimistic did did you work
did you work with them to build this
character what did you bring to it was
there ad libbing well I remember when
they pitched the movie to me they were
like oh she's like relentlessly happy
and she's so upbeat and so positive
about things and I was like I think
you've got the wrong but I feel like we
when we did the sessions like I couldn't
help but be like a little off a little
psychotic and they like really embraced
that and I think especially in that song
get back up again you're like
she is unhinged and unbalanced a little
troll um so I think that you know we
wanted to make her really happy but not
like the kind of thing you couldn't
stand for a 90 minute movie right and um
yes and she's a she's got layers she's
you know she's messed up it's it's the
kind of tiny troll that I like well Mike
and wall and Gina uh to make this movie
let's just say it the world right now is
a cynical toilet
and yes it is there's one convention
going on here that I'm excited to be at
the other one not so much
but uh what is happening what is
happening I don't know what you thought
I was talking about what is happening in
the world and why do you think juelia's
freaky to watch though yeah there's
other trolls over there but uh their
hair what why was it important to make a
movie about optimism and hope and
happiness
well we talked earlier really got into
the theme of happiness and it just seems
timely like that's the news is
depressing and it's and and we're really
excited to make a film that would
literally make people happy make them
laugh make them feel good and have a
movie that's very colorful what's
important to me as well not only dealing
with where does happiness come from the
theme of happiness but actually making
you feel happy when you watch it yeah
giving that happy feeling we did too
much research yeah what you did research
on hugs even yeah we learned that you
know for a hug to work it has to last
seven seconds with the dopamine to work
but HR always makes sure it's a little
bit I always pull away from Walt at six
seconds I have chatty I pull away I
leave them wanting more
let everyone turn to your neighbor and
hug seven seconds oh oh we don't don't
do it it's just like two seconds too
long though like seven seconds is like
just to make it uncomfortable for you
can start to feel the other person
trying to disengage it can't be like
three more seconds yeah can't that's
right people file complaints branch
those seems to be seems to have no hope
he's he's gray he seems pessimistic why
would it what happened to him uh well
funny enough I
remember you know working with with Mike
and Walt and being extremely concerned
that he was just gonna be like too
cantankerous you know that it was like
no one's gonna like this guy and but I
think we found it that's the beauty of
doing you know something like this is
you can really tinker with the
performances as you just get you have so
much time and you get to review you know
before they really have to have to lock
up the animation but I think we just
found that the you know to
counterbalance you know what what Anna
kind of brought to her character I think
it was um it just became more funny that
they were so polar opposites of each
other and makes the story obviously more
intriguing because they get stuck
together and and um you know hilarity
ensues
there's working on a film like this
actually create more optimism in your
life like when you're going to work and
you have to be over when you're over the
top well for instance we you know you
mentioned can't stop the feeling I've
never written a song like that under
these type of circumstances you know but
when I started to write the song it I
was like this actually makes me feel
really good you know and and you know I
think to to kind of go along with the
theme of the movie like you know Mike
and Walt said it's you know it's it's
it's nice to have something you know to
be a part of something that you can put
out in the world and it just like makes
people happy yeah you know and there's
no rhyme or reason to it and you can be
unabashed about it and it helped with
that so that's my favorite thing about
this whole thing
and your song helped with the
storytelling too can water clapped it
was your idea to make well it is it is
such a strange time and I think people
are so accustomed to negativity and I
think people falsely associate the idea
that negativity is more authentic or
more real and even when you put
something out that's really optimistic
people like hey what do you what's your
angle and you're like it's literally
make people happy I mean how did this
affect you Anna
I mean every time I got an email that
said that these guys wanted to do
another session I was like like made my
week I was like looking forward to it
all week because getting to go in and
like
say these weird lines about cupcakes and
rainbows and um and you know just be so
excited about you know rescuing her
friends was really cool and she's like
she's going on an adventure too you know
so it felt like I I got to just like
play inside this tiny six inch pink
little troll and that was so much fun
um so I loved making it I look like I
honestly felt exhausted and happy after
every session do you know what can you
tell us about the rest of the cast oh
yes we have an incredible cast the list
so big I have to read it um Zooey
Deschanel is playing our sweet Bridget
character Christopher mintz-plasse plays
her love interest King Drasil the
petulant King gristle and then we have
all Poppy's best friends a snack pack
James Corden Russell Brand Gwen Stefani
Ron Funches Kunal Nayyar Icona pop and
Cove enginee Wallace I said that all in
one breath um
Rhys Darby from Flight of the Conchords
plays ah be hurry
bobbies Tommy and the brilliant Jeffrey
Tambor plays Poppy's dad and the Bergen
King is hilarious John Cleese and our
chillin villain chef is played by the
amazing Christine Baranski Wow
that's an incredible cast good catch you
guys I assume you guys couldn't record
as a group did you do you have to
piecemeal it because everyone's
schedules yeah we do that a lot in
animation yeah but try to get me Mike
really mediocre impressions of everyone
yeah yeah we do I do a mean act well you
do you did use Boyd a bunch of oice in
the movie was a cloud guy yeah this
guy's cloud Kawakami cloud guy it was it
was an honor to do a voice you guys got
really creative with that character name
by the way we thought very busy cloud
and he's a guy I don't know took weeks
weeks you know when we're making the
film you know you were Mike and I
storyboard a lot of it you know cocktail
napkins we put it on the wall and we're
pitching it and we start putting voices
of these things and so a lot of times if
we're lucky the voices stick
and this time I was lucky to make a
movie like this you record a couple
years ago I would imagine you guys
record but the process is a lot longer
for you so how long is the process and
what is your favorite part of this whole
thing right here huh report
I'm not kidding he has with diameter I'm
kidding you're my people recording music
on this film was really my favorite part
I mean I know we have other favorite
parts but that was just a true watch and
adjust it working together was like a
magic trick Walton I always said like
it's just incredible to watch them
seeing and work and it's great and we
record for about two years as were it's
like workshopping a play yeah yeah we
recorded last week yeah we did yeah our
last going yeah
did you did Anat did you and Justin
record together or do you guys where did
you go record separately oh we record
some stuff together but um the singing
every time I sing Justin was like behind
the booth so I felt like I was in one of
those movies about you know musicians
and he's the guy pressing the button
being like do it better let's do this
next take for real you know we're
recording this right I mean you
obviously everyone knows you have an
amazing voice you people have heard you
sing before but why did oh a gust of
wind made your hair blowing why don't
you record more music why is why isn't
there more Anna Kendrick music in the
world yes and why why Anna we're gonna
get annoyed if I keep doing that
no no I think I think I think that's all
in your head I think people would like
that what is it that you really want to
do what would be exciting well the weird
thing is I played one of the songs from
the movie for a friend of mine the very
first song in the movie and he was like
you sound more like yourself your
singing voice sounds most like it is in
real life in this movie like not the
temperature into the woods or any those
like and I was like that's actually kind
of weird that this like tiny troll is
the closest to like what I sound like in
this power what
in the car so I thought that was
actually really cool yeah have you done
voiceover stuff before have you done
cartoons before Justin I have done a
little bit yes yeah and do you like the
process and do you like hearing your
talking voice and seeing the characters
do you like that part of it um well it's
it's kind of it's fun to kind of alter
your voice in certain ways um for for
you know voice work for animation um but
I I find myself going like you know it's
hard to watch yourself or listen to
yourself it you know cuz then you'll
just sort of critique it but with this
one you know we've we ended up going to
Cannes Film Festival and did a big
presentation and and showed some clips
and then you know obviously we just
showed you guys this sort of I was like
wow this is a big chunk of the movie you
guys but hey cool um um but I find that
and and you can probably attest we both
kept walking running run like we're like
back there the whole time going like
like watching it and enjoying it and
like I said it's it I think it's maybe
the first time that I've you know been a
part of yeah the first time I've ever
rushed to watch footage yeah where
you're sort of in it yeah so I think it
says a lot about about the um I think it
says a lot about this epidemic of
happiness that exactly I can spread I'd
never met you before and you're like the
nicest guy in the world you know you're
Justin Timberlake right if you want to
take people would be fine with it they
would be fine with it be like yeah it's
Justin Timberlake uh well now you've
made me feel awkward you know what that
means
hug talk time seven seconds Oh
long see all right one second too long
second here I'm gonna get fired you've
been working yeah I gotta go to HR you
smell really good bet you I appreciate
that you will not be saying that by the
end of comedy yeah blue a list of things
that have never been said at comic-con
before you smell really good
10 a.m. on Thursday you smell great at
5:00 p.m. on Sunday it's a seasonal part
but uh just the last thing that that
they brought to show you is obviously we
talked about a little bit of beginning
but music being a very important part of
telling this story obviously so tell
everyone what you brought I watched the
piece last night and it's amazing Jimmy
said uh so um so here's what's happened
in the story is I'm gonna spoil it all
papi fails she doesn't save her friends
and and they they're put and it's not
just her friends the entire troll
community is put into a giant flambe pot
and they're going to be served at this
Bergen celebration that the Bergen is
called troll Stace and they're going to
eat tried it you get it troll stirs
churros so they're in a big giant flambe
pot and they're going to be served up
and all is lost and poppy has been super
positive through this whole journey and
um and this troll loses hope when a
troll loses hope their color fades they
just drain of color they become branch
so she drains and she becomes grey and
all of her people see their queen lose
her color and then the whole community
they all drain of color all of her
friends everyone all the trolls drain
and branch is surrounded by all these
trolls that have become him what is he
gonna do it's very sad but if you're
like and then they all get eaten good
night thanks for coming out yeah what
have a good time we have dancing
penguins hey now you're a rock star get
your game on whoa you're doing a lot to
bring to bring a positive spin the name
troll which I usually think of as a guy
with cheeto dust in his neck beard on
the internet telling me I ruined the
walking dead
wrong uh so is there anything else you
wanna the movie by the way it comes out
November 4th comes out November 4th of
this year this is never again
never-before-seen footage please I hope
you didn't record it please don't post
it anywhere this is just special for us
before we set people have take this
pictures or anything you guys want to
say about the movie before we release
you into the wilds of San Diego can I
talk a second about body image yes
please we'd love to just talk about that
for a second as filmmakers we feel is
our responsibility to give girls
memorable characters that don't make
them feel inadequate in body image and
we broke every princess rule in the book
on this one and we kept the troll shapes
around
Shoeless a princess Oh uncountable shoes
right no more and my daughter's 11 she's
a really powerful mind and I'd rather
have her using it too for it to be
imaginative instead of obsessing in the
mirror because all girls are beautiful
I really like their feet that sounded
weird
but I really did like the feet in the
hand like everything you guys could
capture the patrol dollar animated well
so November 4th we're going to stand
everyone up please put on your troll
wings we're going to do a sort of a
reverse shot everyone as many people in
all ages we can cram into this picture
awesome I could only say 20 rows back
there's a lot of there's a book
Justin Timberlake Anna Kendrick tshane
like this
you